time for a bombshell hannity watch on
the deep state tonight
this takes a lot of explaining we're
going to make it very
understandable break it down for you
it's
the abuse of power corruption remember
we've been telling you all about this
it is tonight far worse than we have
ever known up until this point
we now know top people within the fbi
filled with hatred and frankly
anti-trump
rage have put us all eyed all values
and their blatant political bias were
seeking redemption for the firing of
james comey
they actually plotted to destroy your
duly elected president
and this goes way beyond what we already
knew up until this point
now according to this report friday new
york times as usual anonymous sources
two days after comey was unceremoniously
terminated
several top fbi officials actually
questioned whether or not president
trump was working directly for russia
now they did this without a single shred
of evidence
zero probable cause zero
proof of any collusion it was a witch
hunt the president's been right from day
one
they opened an investigation into
whether or not russia directed the
president
to fire their beloved trump hater james
comey
now this despite comey's testimony that
there was no evidence of collusion
for nine months they had been looking
into this and that trump was not the
target of his investigation
remember even comey the trump hater that
he is
admitted that the president could fire
him for any reason
nobody in the media seems to want to
tell you that now congressman john
ratcliffe told our own catherine
herridge quote
in may of 2017 political bias infected
senior fbi leadership and emotion
not evidence drove their decision making
now his closed-door interview with the
former fbi council james baker
revealed this this is important quote
fbi senior leadership could not
accept that comey was fired for cause
and the president
had the constitutional authority to
terminate comey
so they began the witch hunt which had
already started nine months earlier
now president trump's former attorney
john dowd
has called the fbi's anti-trump
operations
a political coup watch this
little did i know that it appears that
they were all in it together uh i mean
rosenstein call me
mueller became the whole crowd
and that they were out to get this
president no matter what
i don't think they sincerely believed
anything about russia
this is our worst nightmare that someone
with that kind of power
would then decide to go after the
president i mean it's a coup
that's why it's an attempted coup by
combing his crowd
and the evidence is all this is all now
there i take the new york times article
as an admission of their bad behavior
admission of corruption and abuse of
power
by people that are unchecked a
bureaucracy
unto itself unlimited powers no
accountability
is any of this good for america do these
deep state officials that we have been
just
uncovering now for nearly two years did
they do anything other
these top officials than hate the
president and are you really surprised
remember
these are the same bureaucrats they
openly rooted for hillary clinton to win
the election peter strzok
texting that hillary clinton should win
100 million to zero
and of course said all those horrible
things about the president the same
officials
who wrote an exoneration in may of 2016
months before actually interviewing
hillary and 16 other witnesses
in july before they exonerated her it
was already written the exoneration
before the investigation the same people
that yawned
we know it is incontrovertible hillary
clinton
obstructed justice she destroyed
subpoenaed emails 33
000 of them washed her hard drive with
bleach bit
smashing smartphones and iphones with a
hammer and taking away sim cards
the same people who look the other way
when hillary
and the dnc funneled money through
perkins cooy a law firm
a campaign finance violation to hire an
op research firm
to hire oh christopher steele a foreign
national
to give us russian lies the same
bureaucrats
who all but applauded when clinton's
funneled cash
used to hire christopher steele why to
produce
a dossier that we now know were full of
lies misinformation
propaganda about president trump which
we now know today are debunked the same
people
who helped disseminate those russian
lies that she paid for
to you the american people and
throughout the highest levels of our
government doing that
before an election so-called trusted
officials who use the dossier
to defraud a fisa court multiple times
to spy on a trump campaign associate by
the way fraud before the court
the same people who use that dossier to
open up an investigation
into trump this all has happened
and yeah a baseless investigation into a
president being controlled
by russia is now just par for the course
and the hysteria the media is even worse
remember this was nine months after they
already been
investigating so-called collusion and by
nine months period of time
lisa page peter strzok james comey
andrew mccabe
all hey trump all said they had nothing
former clinton pollster mark penn who
recently wrote an op-ed
he points out the blatant unequal
justice under the law
quote somehow every clear security
breach in the clinton camp was no big
deal
while every fourth hand contact with
someone who could possibly be linked to
russia
was evidence that donald trump was
secretly serving as a russian agent
now a former assistant director of
intelligence at the fbi
is rightly calling out his old
colleagues for this
massive abuse of power take a look
are we criminalizing or are we are we
exercising the authorities the
legitimate authorities of the fbi
to investigate policy differences to
investigate
foreign policy stances by an
administration well that's not the role
of the fbi
no it's not and despite everything we
just showed you the special counsel
investigation rolls on
they're not looking into hillary clinton
or phony russian dossier that she paid
for
their focus is singularly on president
trump
and everyone around him however tonight
at least one so-called journalist from
the hate trump media
is trying to play down expectations well
people are hyping up every second every
minute every hour of every day
about trump and russia and about the
mueller report take a look
what i am getting is that this is all
building up to the mueller report
and raising expectations of a bombshell
report and there have been expectations
that have been building
of course for over a year on this but
people who are closest
uh to what mueller has been doing have
interacted with the special counsel
cautioned me that this report is almost
certain to be anti-climatic
anti-climatic honestly i don't trust
what you just heard
given the overwhelming partisan makeup
of mueller's team
and their behavior throughout this
process consisting of high-powered
democratic donors and attorneys
uh mark my words they have and will
continue to destroy the presidency of
donald trump they've been doing it now
for two years and they did it before the
election
here's the problem this is what you
concern every american tonight if the
these deep state actors succeed forget
about free
and a fair justice system it's done
equal justice under the law
application of our laws dead in america
might as well take the constitution as
we know it
shred it because that's over forever
never forget the hate trump democrats
hate
trump media they have been tied at the
hip the whole time
reporting innuendo lies conspiracies
daily
just like last week remember we saw the
talking point of the democratic party
regurgitated by their friends in the
media a manufactured crisis at the
border
no people getting killed and drugs
crossing our border that's real
and speaking of which we continue our
hannity watch tonight on the government
shutdown
and the real crisis at our southern
border that the media refuses to
acknowledge
so with budget negotiations still
deadlocked and after nearly 10 whole
days on the job many congressional
democrats
they treated themselves after 10 days to
some well-deserved rest and relaxation
at an oceanfront luxury resort and on
friday senator bob menendez and at least
29 other democratic lawmakers
they boarded a private jet wait a minute
oh what about carbon emissions and went
to san juan puerto rico
where they spent the next few days
soaking up the sun right there on the oh
that's such a nice picture they're
working so hard
for we the people and then they attended
a special viewing
of the broadway hit play hamilton and
hanging out with over
oh a hundred lobbyists and corporate
executives
that's what you do on the tenth day on
the job good job
uh who paid for the plane who paid for
the tickets just a question we don't
have answers yet
but while these democrats having fun in
the sun lavish vacations
a 10 day can you imagine 10 days having
you know
greg jarrett 10 days and then you go on
vacation
i think i want that job i'm going to run
for office meanwhile we have a crisis at
our southern border and it's gotten
worse
while they're on vacation a brand new
migrant caravan is forming in honduras
this major group of migrants scheduled
to depart tomorrow morning
planning to cross our borders at an
unknown time and location
this coming as we're learning about a
dangerous federal loophole
leaving all americans vulnerable to
violent gangs now
we told you the story last week two high
school students
brutally assaulted stabbed by three
illegal immigrants with ms-13 ties
two of the three illegal immigrants were
previously released
after committing other crimes in the
united states when they were detained
because they were quote unaccompanied
minors at the time of their unauthorized
entry
into the united states across the border
americans
what we're going to die because of open
borders democrats
they don't seem to care last friday on
this program
you met mothers and fathers on their
show that lost
their children because of the illegal
immigrants that were in the justice
system
and we never sent them or deported them
back to their home country
president he's working close on this to
close the loopholes
actually secure the border to help save
american lives
democrats are on vacation just like they
were over christmas nowhere to be found
maybe the president should offer them a
tropical vacation if they can get the
job done
now sadly it's become abundantly clear
we now have
a far left takeover of the democratic
party
and that brings us tonight to our
hannity watch on socialism
so the democrats new star new york
congresswoman alexandria
ocasio cortez she's been on immediate
terror
moving her party further and further to
the left with calls for a
70 percent tax rate she wants to abolish
ice
oh that's not like they'll lose their
jobs i thought democrats cared about
paychecks
also government mandated climate shaming
policies in other words
they're coming for every last penny now
these are the same socialized
socialist ideas that are gaining
momentum look at new york and california
two examples new york city
comrade mayor bill de blasio appears to
be eyeing
a new far left scheme to redistribute
wealth saying
this in his recent state of the city
address in new york take a look
millions of people in this city tens of
millions across the country are boxed
into lives that just aren't working for
them
you haven't been paid what you deserve
for all the hard work you haven't been
given the time you deserve
you're not living the life you deserve
and here is the cold hard truth
it's no accident it's an agenda
an agenda that's dominated our politics
from reaganomics
to the trump tax giveaway to the wealthy
and corporations
here's the truth brothers and sisters
there's
plenty of money in the world
there's plenty of money in this city
it's just
in the wrong hands at least comrade de
plazio wants to
confiscate money it's in the wrong hands
don't be fooled this isn't about
compassion
it's always about power bigger
government finding new reasons to tax
and control hard-working americans in
this case new yorkers
you've seen the same thing in california
radical leftist governor gavin newsom
well he may be out doing a wall he now
is going to tax
drinking water this will require
californians to pay an extra tax
to ensure that the water they drink is
clean remember this is a state with a 13
and a half percent inc state income tax
this is a party devoid of moderates and
their solution
every problem is make more and take more
of your hard-earned money
and pretend it's for your benefit in
other words you surrender freedom
for false security when really it's
about government control over your life
all while
of course covering up their own
incompetence